I'm a mom to a three year old girl
and I believe that by the time she's an adult,
we will have a free Palestine.
We're standing outside post DNC.
Pamela is just on payday. How do you feel right now?
I wish that I could celebrate right now.
Mama's supposed to feel joy.
Ask about a speaker on that stage.
The fact that they weren't allowed even five minutes.
This could have been a gesture of goodwill.
They could have done that
and they didn't do that. We are the party of the rights.
We are the only party that will guarantee.
We are the only party that is talking about banning assault weapons.
I'm a lifelong Democrat
and work elect Democrats up and down the ballot.
I want my hair to be the best candidate possible.
We had so many politicians.
Horsewoman Corey Bush, Summer Lee,
Representative Ilhan Omar.
Their movement is just gonna grow and grow,
and in the last 24 hours, it's grown a lot. So I am very hopeful.